i keep getting
kind of a famous feeling and anytime i
get a famous feeling it usually
indicates that somebody is either
renowned or connected to celebrities or
connected to like an iconic historical
figure or fake
you get kind of get the gist with it
you're right on
as he always is that was a clip from
tyler henry's new netflix series life
after death with tyler henry and joining
us now is the world-renowned clairvoyant
medium himself tyler so good to see you
i'm so glad to be back thank you for
having me congratulations on the new
series you are back on our screens after
three years what was it like and what
made you want to get the cameras rolling
again well you know this show is so
different than hollywood medium over the
past three years we think have all been
through so much as a society
individually and i think a lot of people
have really had time to think about
mortality and purpose and so i feel like
the show is very timely and really
meeting that demand of everyday clients
regular people who really needed a
reading and were able to get it and some
were surprises some of them they were
expecting but the results were always
you know kind of unpredictable you never
knew what was going to happen was that
always the intention going into kind of
tyler henry 2.0 is to dive into the wait
list that has over 300 000 people
waiting for readings with you yes that
was always the goal was to meet that
demand you know i enjoyed hollywood
medium and doing that show and
catering to celebrities on that show but
for me my passion has always been
helping everyday people i'm an everyday
person i grew up in a small town in
central california and so it was kind of
hearkening back to why i first started
doing these readings was for people who
really needed it people who might not be
able to come to la and so i got to
travel to them and what's cool too is
you're even helping find people like
private investigators find answers when
i saw you on tv so much with the stars
i was so hoping as a private
investigator and in my cases that you
being so young and your energy and your
passion if we could use some of that
towards cases you know cold cases new
cases that it would help so much what i
love about the show is i really pushed
my ability to its limits and you'll see
that as you watch the episodes ranging
from working with a private investigator
um you know to really applying my
ability in even different ways you know
something that we're also seeing with
the series 2 is a more vulnerable side
of you you open up about your own past
struggles with suicidal thoughts health
issues your family's past trauma
how difficult was it for you to
literally lay it all out there in front
of the cameras knowing that it's going
to be seen by millions of people the
whole world and you know i think there's
power in owning our story and owning
that vulnerability and i think for me i
learned through these readings that so
often people resonated with these
readings because the clients were in a
place of honesty and vulnerability and
owning that human aspect that kind of
interconnects us all so for me the show
was an opportunity to do that very thing
to own my story without fear and just to
let people know that you know no matter
what you're going through you can get
through the other side of it what's so
fascinating too is not only are you
reading everyday people during these
episodes as they play out but you're
also we're watching your own storyline
play out as well with you and your mom
trying to find answers with your own
past family issues i'm
maybe never gonna know
what happened yeah
we're not talking about a woman who made
a mistake or two we're talking about
stella
who has a lifetime
a lifetime
of ruining people's lives how difficult
was that for you to see her struggling
and hitting roadblocks as she was trying
to find answers that she so desperately
wanted you know people come to me for
answers or clarity and my goals always
try to provide something along those
lines if i can and so to see my mom who
needed so badly answers herself but to
not be able to be the source of those
answers
kind of how the tables turned on me i
think it was almost a kind of a
universal irony there that i could do
this for others but when it came time
for myself i needed help from other
resources
as a kid i was told that my mom's mom
had spent time in prison this was no
secret considering she served 30 years
and for a good portion of my childhood
was in the pin in recent years we
discovered through a genealogy test that
my mother was not actually related to
the parents she thought were her parents
for the first 50-something years of her
life this culminated in a discovery that
my mom was actually taken as a child
and the woman who took her later went on
to commit multiple homicides and spent
over 30 years in prison so only recently
did my mom know that she had a loving
family that had dedicated their whole
lives to looking for her and just was
never able to find her because this
criminal had taken her and
hidden her away
in states away from where she was born
so it was an incredible story of
resilience identity and going back and
really figuring out where we come from
who we are and nature versus nurture you
know by the end of the season
there's still some more answers to be
found could this open the door set the
stage for possibly another season oh yes
and there's a lot that wasn't included
in this season about the story that i
think people will find very interesting
and could definitely set the stage for a
second season and there's a lot more
people on that wait list too that's
right plenty of mysteries to explore
both personally and professionally
speaking of personally we get to see a
lot more of your boyfriend clint in this
series as well now how does that work
when it comes to tapping into
your own personal life are there things
that you don't want
the spirits to tell you about possibly
your future with someone sure well you
know i always say it helps to read
strangers who i don't know or don't know
anything about because i don't have bias
but when it comes to ourselves we have
implicit bias right we have our own
hopes and fears and concerns so it is a
little bit more challenging reading
myself but i would say my ability and
intuition has allowed me to get a sense
of who i resonate with and who i don't
and that is immensely valuable in kind
of getting an understanding of who is a
likely candidate for a long-term
relationship right or a long-term
friendship so you got good vibes with
this good vibe we're half a decade in i
feel like it's a testament to that and i
hope we have many more i love seeing how
far you've come in your professional
life and your personal life where do you
still want to continue to grow and go to
from here on out you know i think ever
reading teaches me something new and i
think makes me a better medium and a
better person and so in whatever way i
can explore those messages those themes
and just bringing in awareness that you
know love doesn't end when people pass
away
however i can manifest that message i'm
very thankful and you're putting those
messages into another book here and here
after which is out on march 29th what
can fans expect with this work of art to
put it concisely this book really for me
was about if the departed could do it
differently if they could do it over
what would they do
and you know in this these readings i've
done i've seen the power of regret in
people's lives and how they wish things
could have been said or done i know
you're booked and busy but do you still
have time to read celebrities as well
you know i really don't dedicate my time
to celebrities so much anymore i i love
the relationships being able to
cultivate and it's been amazing but when
i can i just dedicate my time to
everyday people
you know people who are dealing with
terminal illness i've actually been
doing a number of those readings lately
so that to me is where my ability shines
the most where there's that need
how
special is that to you to be able to
walk away from a reading like that
especially with someone with a terminal
illness knowing how much you've impacted
them just with your ability is so
humbling so humbling every single time i
feel so thankful to be able to be the
catalyst for that but i certainly don't
feel like i leave that wanting to take
credit for it and that's one of those
things i've learned with this work how
humbling it is it reminds me that i'm
about this big and that my job is just
to be the messenger you are a master of
your craft and you're doing such good
work out here because we are
entertainment tonight i do have to ask
you who would be your dream celebrity to
read dream celebrity to read all right
margot robbie would be really
interesting because she's a bit
mysterious okay and i always got to go
back to tanya thicke or not tonya thick
i've already read tanya thick tanya
harding a lot of tanya tanya harding
would be amazing yeah i'm actually going
to be seeing tanya thick here in the
next month she contacted me and we were
actually able to meet after alan's
passing on hollywood medium it was
really cathartic to not only have met
him in life but have him come through
for her it was a really emotional
episode so now that some times passed
i'm looking forward to seeing her here
very soon and this will all be off
camera private reading this one will be
a private reading but it was really a
fascinating demonstration of being able
to meet with someone when they were here
and then when they passed away and a
full circle moment to
of your abilities and your impact on
entire families and the testament that
his love you know was there for her in
life and continues to even on the other
side tyler henry thank you so much for
joining us here at ut everyone you can
check out tyler's new netflix series
streaming now
you